cela en plus y'a des quatre tirs et je
sais que généralement j'en prends plein
la gueule
ça va des années que tu me fais rire
peut-être de ma mère arrête je dois me
faisait rire gt gt dans le dos dans dans
la rue je te regarde et je te regarde
avec des yeux étincelants
c'est mon idée je te jure c'est le pipe
auteurs salue la vingtaine mais il était
sur scène et j'étais vrai ouais c'est ce
à quoi vous mentez mais c'est terrible
mais ça fait plaisir en tout cas bien
merci pour lui elle vole une question
moi je vois bien ses concerts la semaine
précédente à regarder bonjour je
m'appelle brigitte la semaine dernière
en fin d'émission
vous avez demandé à christophe
hondelatte de raconter une histoire
donc je voulais savoir est ce que vous
comptez recommencer car moi ça m'a coupé
envie de finir ma blanquette cette
question la suite mais a priori non je
vous rassure ça n'aurait pas se
reproduire
christophe hondelatte était juste invité
il n'a pas été embauché pour être en
alternance et camille combal
enfin je crois pas alors ce moment il
faut s'attendre à tout avec cyril
quelques ares cellulite qui s'était dit
que c'est que pour bien finir l'émission
une petite histoire de christophe ça
serait sympa que je kiffe bref je me
suis fait moukim gc ca il a fait la même
chose avec laurent baffie problème c'est
que les histoires de longue date il n'y
a pas de chute rigolote mais il ya
beaucoup de morts vous allez voir le
climat sur le plateau c'était
particulier tant que tu ne mourras a
promis de tuer la fille catherine alors
il ne se passera plus rien entre nous et
lui dit mais je te le promets et bien
trouve le mois une première fois elle le
gène elle jette sa petite fille qui a
six ans dans la rivière l'eau n'est pas
profonde en vérité c'est un acte manqué
pour l'art prêche mais il ya des témoins
la deuxième fois et l'oubli au fond
d'une forêt
on la retrouve et on l'a levé il ramène
et à ce moment-là son amant j'avais pour
mission c'était latent peur était il
faut faire un petit focus sur la tête de
série pendant toute l'histoire sa tête
numéro 14
celle du maître concentré ou qui est sur
le point de s'endormir on sait pas trop
vous savez quand vous trouvez une
conversation un peu longue et que vous
faites semblant d'écouter en répétant le
mot de temps en temps pour faire genre
je m'intéresse évidemment il a il la cub
comme on disait à l'époque mais il n'a
qu'une peau si jacques jack chaque c'est
ça un jour de grâce et ça me fâche pas
[ __ ] qu'on n'a pas comme on disait à
l'époque mais il n'a qu'une peau si
jacques baylac jean le cam il est
vraiment menacé son refrain jacques
alors qu'on soit bien d'accord on adore
tous les histoires de christophe
hondelatte
mais l'histoire de la femme qui s'y
prend à plusieurs fois pour tuer son
enfant juste pour faire plaisir à son
amant c'était pas joyeux joyeux mais
c'est pas ça le pire
le pire c'est ce qu'a dit damien canivet
ce juste après les yeux brillant
d'émotion
[Applaudissements]
quand je vous dis quelques des
psychopathes dans cette émission
alors pour que tu t'endors rejettera
côtés de monsieur qui découpe et les
gens pour ce faire des tours de clé
c'est fait bizarre quand même
bon heureusement la plupart du temps tpm
piscine manière plus joyeuse la semaine
dernière par exemple on recevait les
chanteurs de spare 80 km
alors comme dirait s'il ses deux salles
deux ambiances par rapport à christophe
hondelatte le final la semaine dernière
je sais pas si vous vous rappelez bien
sûr il exactement
patrick hernandez fernand et chanter un
de ses tubes enfin d'ailleurs le seul
qu'on connaît born to be alive pour le
plus grand bonheur de maxime gainey qui
était persuadé d'avoir la chorégraphie
ultime alors tu sens que le mec a passé
sa vie dans les mariages
vous allez voir c'est déjà triste quand
il fait une démonstration à gilles
verdez mais qu'en plus il se met à côté
du chanteur pour l'appliquer alors sans
maltsi veut piquer la place de kamel
ouali
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ce chien moi c'est isabelle pauthier pas
lâcher la javel mon cas on dirait tâte
autant cette attente yake qui gagne
soirée et sur qui veut se mettre dans
l'ambiance sympa les jeunes à je vois
qu'on est venus s'encanailler
vous êtes très belle un ouais
franchement un bon on aura dit sabrina
c'est vrai c'était explosif alors été
très réussie je voudrais remercier cyril
pour ça non parce que quelqu'un a une
nouvelle fois vous avez pris sur vous
pour faire le show vous avez dansé à
fond tout donné alors que juste avant je
peux le dire
vous aviez a pris de mauvaises valeurs
et un bataillon la fontaine souvenez
vous c'est vrai qu'il m'a appris une
mauvaise nouvelle alors comme vous êtes
trop pudique pour le dire je voulais
passer cet extrait on vous rendre
hommage et pour que les gens comprennent
que d'avoir le masque de la joie il ya
parfois une soudaine mais c'est avec la
gt venez
[Musique]
et
on
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j
cet arrêt ans julia et valérie oui bien
sûr j'ai fini les missions et tu attends
je ne fais pas ça me comme l'écrit
tartas en fondu slibard espaçant vos
citations sur wikipédia alors le jour de
stars 80 nous avions également plateau
jean pierre mader et là surtout si
sabrina le sosie de d isabelle et
heureusement qu'ils étaient là
jean-pierre parce que sabrina est captée
rien ce qui est logique puisqu'elle est
italienne et qui n'avaient pas tous les
références donc jean-pierre a tout
expliqué pendant l'émission
à sa façon
[Musique]
le cd ainsi armé
[Applaudissements]
les temps oui
[Musique]
c'est marc toussaint 200 m comme la tour
eiffel
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
10h à 15h de signes à courber pour les
fenêtres
[Applaudissements]
magnéto préféré social tant débat on
peut pour les faisait bien situé et fort
les katia l'a alors vraiment en ses
rangs ni sur l'autoroute du riz 1
en tout cas j'avais tellement qu'ils
aient autant d'entrées d'entre les
chroniqueurs carlo car je dois la vérité
tpm pc pas toujours un long fleuve
tranquille parfois il ya des désaccords
profonds entre chroniqueurs alors on va
faire un petit jeu je vous montre une
conversation un peu animé entre jean
michel et valérie et vous devrez deviner
de quoi il parlait
[Musique]
m
si tamagnon dix mois donc là on sent que
c'est un sujet sensible
d'après vous de quoi parlait jean michel
quel était le sujet de la dispute et du
sexe je suis sûr que jean michel se
souvient même pas ouais non non non à
l'otan sans rigoler on dirait qu'elle
est non il dévoile dans ce non ce n'est
pas du sexe je vois pas de bonnes choses
la réponse en images vous trouvera
jamais
[Musique]
sa part
aulas
je veux aller courir
si on comptait garder rachid arradon
2010 un coup dur sa couture print
jean-michel dans la gueule là et en
condition jean-michel semaine dernière
vous avez révélé qu'il allait participer
à une émission scientifique avec maxime
gainey s'est presque pas sorcier
alors lors du premier numéro il devait
expliquer ce qu'était la potomanie là il
va encore plus loin il s'était carrément
à albert einstein
[Musique]
wigan c'est de ça veut dire quoi selon
toi vas-y jeux nrj
oui égal m mas hamas c'est le sénat
c'est quoi accoyer
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
sarkozy sait pas quoi faire la
conversation
voilà non moi c'est l'autre côté j'ai
plus chiffres ou moi je vais me remettre
2 mai sarah t j avais plus chiffres mais
mr 617 ça fait une très bonne transition
pour le top gène ans ça sera au top la
semaine prochaine mais là c'est bon il
fait ça en direct
j'ai donc cesser ces petits moments qui
se passe que dans touche pas à mon poste
[Musique]
me carlo jean-luc voilà tous les prendre
pour sa part d'audience
wattez
[Musique]
c'est eux
la queue est tournée
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
chacun car je trouvais que tu m'aimes tu
ta petite fille katherine la mère
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors je vous dire on a toujours le
temps dans un instant il y aura cécile
de minibus qui sera au coeur de la
police municipale il ya de la police et
vous allez voir donner à cécile qui va
cartonner
c'est parti c'est police secours
d'ailleurs tous les programmes de cible
bon alors depuis quelques temps c'est la
lancer un jeu des chiffres dermal à je
vous connais le principe est simple s'il
pose des questions les chroniqueurs
essaye de répondre et à la fin c'est
donner point benjamin
sauf que ça plaît pas à tout le monde ça
par exemple maxime gagné sur le sujet il
est très très premier degré mais ça
m'énerve je pense qu'il croit qu'il ya
encore vraiment quelque chose à gagner
n'est pas là dessus rien passé je vous
ai fait une petite copine 86 mois
[Applaudissements]
voulait privilégier 17h comme bonnes
réponses
[Applaudissements]
brassant celui qui en fait c'est barbara
castle bientôt vous tendez la boîte à
tout le temps il ya très beaux cadeaux à
gagner à la fin mai juste un combat
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
réponse demande m'agace a dit je ne peux
pas grave tu déconnes
à chaque fois les chouchous maxime il a
envie de dire crottes
mais heureusement dans ces bons la
coller un peu énervé quand elle un petit
coup au moral
il peut se reposer sur sa complicité
légendaire avec gibernau
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les deux heures
évidemment de temps en temps les deux
discute vraiment la preuve avec ce bel
échange le jour de la venue de vianney
ce qui rappelait de jolis souvenirs à
maxime gagné
[Musique]
mauvais
[Applaudissements]
d'excellents je vous dirai comment votre
conseil de classe bon vivant à l'étang
de passer à tous qu'on n'aurait pas
voulu voir et entendre cette semaine et
on commence par cyril car nous donne le
secret de ce qu'est une émission réussie
pour lui
[Musique]
c'est sympathique j'aime bien les
missions concentrer son brassard
vous envoyez la musique trop tôt voilà
trop tôt quand je dirais musique merde
il va pas tarder à nous faire chier
vous êtes magnifique vraiment et je
voulais je vous fasse un aveu je vous
trouve encore plus belle maintenant qu'à
mon ma mère si vous savez non mais
vraiment vous êtes de plus en plus jolie
merci alors maintenant ses mots et bien
sûr sophie davant on la retrouve tous
les matins dans ses bras et voilà qu'ils
sont mille milliards de fois nous
pensons en trombe le mur des molécules
est complètement mutique a dit c'est qui
qu'a dit j'ai vu ton anus tu dois partir
babbitt non car j'en reconnais mais non
les jeunes si j'ai vu que j'aime et à
captieux local d'arrêter rapidement
c'est un [ __ ] de merde parce que je
suis cette émission
[Musique]
les unités là
c'est changer le nom maxime et s'il n'y
avait pas de victimes de viol
[Musique]
vous répondez vous m'aimez son arrivée
entre les phrases homicide victoire